[Musique]
caché au coeur de la montagne des andes
c'est une prouesse architecturale
construite il y a plus de 500 ans par
les incas on croyait presque tout savoir
sur la cité perdue du machu picchu elle
n'a pourtant pas encore révélé tous ses
secrets
c'est sur sa route au coeur de la vallée
sacrée que l'archéologue rosset bas
stand t&d par une équipe de chercheurs
polonais a récemment fait une découverte
un système de canalisation caché dans le
sol
elle initie reste à l'eau était
canalisée depuis la rivière cha cha bond
à
béziers hélas le des sondés par ces
canaux et alimenter les fontaines
servait au rituel de purification
c'est en suivant la trace de ces canaux
que l'archéologue et son éclipse sont
tombés sur une cité ensevelie par la
végétation
attention un serpent
voici un exemple de construction qu'on a
découvert grâce à la technologie du
drone l'ida
et c'est un tort c'est une construction
de format carré là et vous voyez ici la
végétation a presque fait disparaître
ces miracles
c'est pierre n'ont pu être identifiés
que grâce à un drone spécifique équipés
de faisceaux de lumière qui ont permis
de cartographier en 3d ces restes de
construction
appuis dont il gît un plus grand nombre
de structures et
les années qui viennent on va réaliser
des fouilles ici pour comprendre à quoi
servaient ces constructions quelles
étaient leurs fonctions précises
de nouvelles découvertes qui ne s'arrête
pas là
recouverte par la végétation pendant
près de quatre cents ans avant d'être
révélée officiellement au monde en 1911
la cité sacrée du machu picchu est
depuis en constante restauration ses
mystères son père s'est progressivement
récemment les archéologues ont élucidé
l'utilité de ce bâtiment en instruments
astronomiques taillé à même la pierre
la lumière du solstice d'été rentrée ici
egret à un faisceau de lumière qui
disparaissait quelques minutes après
l'essai
les inquiète définissez ainsi la
meilleure époque pour planter le maïs
dans les terres agricoles situées devant
ce que l'on veut c'est connaître le plus
possible des us et coutumes des
habitants sous l'ère
quel était leur relation avec la nature
avec les dieux
et le fait d'avoir construit un
instrument pareil entre bien le pouvoir
d un quart face aux phénomènes naturels
et aux mouvements du soleil tout au long
de l'année
le machu picchu était abandonnée lors de
la conquête de l'empiré inca par les
espagnols au 16e siècle les rares
trésors encore découvert aujourd'hui
sont conservés au musée du site où ils
sont étudiés et restaurés comme ce
soulier en fibres végétales
voici une sandale qui a été retrouvé
dans la zone du sanctuaire
les archéologues ont aussi trouvé ses
broches en cuivre mais le plus
impressionnant pour ce conservateur ce
sont ces céramiques
présentation il servait de contenants
pour la chicha le liquide sakhri qu'ils
utilisaient pour vénérer le soleil et la
terre mère
si on prend cet exemple on a récupéré
95% des fragments de ce vase il est
presque complet mais c'est aujourd'hui
très rare de retrouver des pièces
entières comme ça
enfin céramiste grand astronome et
ingénieur agronome expérimenter les
inquiète leurs prouesses architecturales
continue de faire rêver des milliers de
touristes chaque année comme cette
famille venue de france c'est
impressionnant c'est vrai qu'on voit
beaucoup de photos partout et ça va
c'est mieux en vrai qu est ce que vous
imaginez alors il ya 500 ans de l'or de
l'argent partout et pas mal de rituel
c'est la page fan peut-être
le vrai trésor du machu picchu ce sont
ces temples et ses pierres pour les
protéger de l'érosion les autorités ont
fixé une limite de 1000 visiteurs
quotidiens
[Musique]